odessa hasn't looked like this since the
nazis invaded 80 years ago
then it held for 70 days this time if
the russians do come who knows
traditionally it's a russian-speaking
town sympathetic to moscow but that's
evaporated in recent weeks
of russian military personnel
and putin's spokesman's denial of the
killing of civilians
isn't convincing to many
he was not really sure
what his he said deny deny
we don't have facts this is fake but he
he as a spokesman
didn't have enough
like investigation research in his hands
i feel
that he was a little bit weak
ukrainians here in the south have not
just seen the horrors left behind when
the russian tide retreated in the north
those trying to push back here say
they're witnessing the same thing
daniel salem has just returned from
fighting in russian held her song
people are lying dead on the streets
that said with civilians
women children
grown-up people
it's the same thing as butchers the
whole ukraine is like that right now
this pedestrianized area is where
families would normally come to enjoy
the restaurants and the shops but it is
deadly quiet this ancient city has been
fortifying and holding its breath since
the conflict began
president zielenski told the greek
parliament that putin wants to do to
odessa what he's already done to marry a
pole and the only reason he hasn't
achieved it yet is because the russian
forces have been held back
the kremlin may have nostalgia for this
port city's imperial history but it's
not reciprocated if russia comes odessa
will resist
jason farrell sky news odessa